[Música]
[Aplausos]
outro dia eu cheguei em casa e fui falar
com o meu filho de quatro anos
eu estava brincando com uma máquina de
calcular antiga e eu falei assim filho
queria conversar com você está fazendo o
cálculo ele fez assim espera
eu estou lendo as mensagens depois eu te
respondo eu naquele momento meu coração
partiu em pedaços e eu me dei conta de
que na verdade eu estava como a maior
parte de nós brasileiros que era ficando
quase dez horas por dia online
e mesmo quando chegava em casa eu
continuava no meu celular
respondendo os meus pacientes inclusive
achando naquele momento que aquilo era
muito importante que o meu filho
repetindo que eu estava fazendo
vamos lá
essa senhora ela tem 75 anos
ela adora falar que os exames delas não
tem nada
ela não toma nenhuma medicação ela
começou a nadar aprendeu a nadar aos 60
anos e começou a correr aos 70 porque
ela tem né que poderia ser tão especial
por enquanto que eu posso dizer para
vocês é que ela é neta de italianos como
esses italianos que foram estudar nos
estados unidos na cidade de rosetto na
pensilvânia
porque apesar deles estarem nos estados
unidos entre 55 e 65 anos não existia
nenhuma morte por infarto
vocês podiam pensar assim é um estilo de
vida europeu
acontece que a maioria deles estava
acima do peso
fumava muito bebia muito e eram em sua
maioria sedentários
um médico foi estudar junto com o
sociólogo pensou vamos ver o que tem de
diferente nessa população que vocês
poderiam pensar também será que é
genético
acontece que quando essas pessoas se
mudavam para nova york uma cidade que se
comporta muito parecida né aqui como são
paulo
essa proteção se perdia que será que
tinha com esse pessoal é só mostrar uma
coisa pra vocês rosetto que a cidade 0
quando você vai para cidades próximas
chega a mil e 500 mortes nesse período
por 100 mil habitantes
o zeito tinha 0
bom vamos lá essa lá na roseta
as pessoas moravam em até três gerações
na mesma casa
as portas eram abertas para quem
quisesse entrar não existia uma
diferenciação socioeconômica que se
destacasse as pessoas que tinham mais
oportunidades elas não ostentavam e as
que tinham menos sempre sabiam que
poderiam contar com alguma ajuda
e essa senhora de 75 anos
essa senhora pra casa da minha mãe e
desde que eu era criança eu ea minha
irmã gente ia pra alguma padaria
supermercado fim feira
se alguém viesse falar com ela qualquer
coisa poderia ser tipo tração
eu ia mesmo a gente a vontade de
desaparecer
principalmente quando a gente era
adolescente que olha para cima assim ela
passava no mínimo meia hora com a pobre
coitada da criatura batendo um papo como
se aquela pessoa tivesse muito
interessado nela
né a gente pede que ela se mude porque
ela não está aqui em são paulo ela disse
eu que não vou perder todas as pessoas
que eu conheço aqui próximo a minha casa
é o padeiro é a pessoa do jornal da
banca é o cabeleireiro é a pessoa que
lava o carro enfim ela tem relação com
todas essas pessoas e quando o time dela
perde é o único momento em que ela se
trancar dentro de casa porque ela adora
mexer com as outras pessoas mas não quer
que ninguém mexa com ela
isso aqui é o seguinte o que vocês
pensam que protege e dá longevidade a
vida de vocês
geralmente a gente pensa que o show em
são paulo meu filho pelo menos eu
pensava assim
essa poluição isso deve fazer muito mal
realmente uma das coisas que protege é é
a qualidade do ar
mas olha lá a gente até atividade física
protege não deixem de fazer um exercício
mas não vai adiantar nada vocês ficarem
fitch
se vocês não tiverem amizades e convívio
próximo com familiares ou até mesmo a
interação social
vamos lá essa é a turma do instituto de
psiquiatria que eu coordeno da liga de
depressão que a gente observa que os
pacientes que mais melhoram o que a
gente consegue atuar da melhor maneira
são aqueles pacientes que de alguma
forma ou participam dos grupos que a
gente coordena e eles neco os grupos de
psicoterapia ou que tenha alguma família
o que tem algum amigo que vem
acompanhando isso faz toda a diferença é
importante a gente entender o seguinte
sabe aquele amigo que a gente chama para
jantar pra festa pra balada ele nunca
vai a gente pensa assim eu não
amo mais muitas vezes essa pessoa pode
estar na verdade com depressão a
depressão causa isolamento social ea
depressão também é causada pelo
isolamento social
só que vocês possam pensar nisso a
primeira dica
na época eu falo isso tudo fala que vai
ficar doente alguém pode pensar mas eu
sou tímido
alguém pode pensar eu não tenho muitos
amigos eu não sou de são paulo
a primeira dica fala com aquelas pessoas
com quem você cruza todos os dias como a
senhora lá a minha mãe você vai tomar um
café na padaria tem o porteiro do seu
prédio o seu vizinho troca com essas
pessoas
pergunta o nome delas vocês vão ter
gratas surpresas alguma causa algo que
vocês acreditem que vocês acham que faça
a diferença né não adianta também alguma
coisa tava lá ela falou que voluntariado
é bom eu vou lá fazer alguma coisa não
algo que vocês acreditem porque vocês
vão estar próximo de pessoas que tenham
meus mesmos valores que vocês sobre a
questão de conversar com a padaria
estava conversando com a minha irmã
contando que a falar da nossa mãe e ela
também mora em uma outra cidade ela
falou assim ela tirou a tiza pe
ela tirou enfim tudo acontece wilson até
rede social
e ela falou assim ai que bom eu achei
que eu estava ficando doente mas eu sei
o nome de todos os porteiros até o
caminho do meu trabalho eu sei as
pessoas da padaria ela sabe o que eu
gosto e é por aí
qual é o grupo a faixa etária que mais
sofre com a solidão eo isolamento social
são os idosos
a gente precisa pensar nos nossos idosos
as pessoas da nossa família né
é como eu disse rosetto três gerações
ficam na mesma casa as pessoas não
precisam se preocupar por exemplo com a
aposentadoria porque quem vai cuidar
delas vão seus familiares
eu moro em são paulo eu tenho que pegar
trânsito como eu vou fazer
a idéia de poder ajudar esse idoso a
onde ele mora a penetra tocando um pouco
fazendo escalas
família trocando um pouco com a
vizinhança é um jeito da gente cuidar
deles
os meus pacientes idosos eles reclamam
assim puxa
eles ficam me chamando para ir às festas
dos netos e os bisnetos mas eu não vou
chegar lá me deixou largado num canto
ninguém vai falar comigo então a gente
precisa pensar que vamos chegar lá
2 essas pessoas estão querendo conversar
elas têm muito para ensinar pra gente
muito pra falar na experiência de vida e
também vai ser uma experiência muito
interessante poder trocar com elas a
coisa um desafio queria saber o seguinte
que levantasse a mão quem postou que
estava vindo o que estava aqui no ted
esperava quem durante alguma
apresentação foi pro celular trocar
alguma informação com alguém olhasse
elkem de um like porque estava aqui no
ted pessoal tá mais tímido
eu acho que foi mais uma se não fosse
estão de parabéns está o número de
amigos que a gente tem
nas redes sociais o número de curtidas
que a gente recebe
isso não está relacionado com a nossa
saúde muitas vezes que a gente tem visto
são muitos estudos dizendo justamente o
contrário
vamos lá então quando a gente for sair
está pra gente ver com os nossos amigos
uma proposta que eu tenho pra vocês é
pega uma caixinha e coloca em casa vai
todo mundo colocar o celular lá e vocês
vão jantar de verdade conversando e por
que vocês já repararam mas a gente vai
pra show coloca o telefone
as pessoas não vêem o que elas estão
falando né
está em torno delas elas vêem que estão
no celular está numa super paisagem
linda tira fotos segurando o celular né
muitas vezes a gente nem vê os vídeos
que a gente coloca pra gravar
os então estão com os amigos ir uma vez
por semana em casa quando chegar depois
que meu filho fez aquilo né
eu deixo o celular faz nda ele não vai
me ver falando no celular a não ser que
tenha alguma coisa muita gente
então a gente precisa ficar atento a
isso é o seguinte vocês receberam
envelope certo
então tá este envelope eu gostaria que
vocês pensassem em alguém com quem vocês
podem contar
não importa o que tá que conhece o seu
melhor conhece o seu pior que você pode
ligar no meio da noite
se precisar eu queria que vocês
escrevessem uma carta para essa pessoa
agradecendo e em reconhecimento e vocês
vão entregar essa carta pessoalmente
então vale mandar pelo filho pela tirar
uma foto e mandar a marca um café um
encontro rápido assim vocês que sabe
e aí o que vocês também pensassem o
seguinte se por acaso vocês não
conseguirem pensar em ninguém pensa em
alguém pra quem vocês estariam lá não
importa o quê e marque um encontro com
essa pessoa com essa carta dizendo que
essa pessoa pode contar com você tá
quatro em cada desculpa uma em cada
quatro pessoas
não não tem ninguém com quem contar
a gente já está com o mundo assim como a
incidência ou não uma a cada quatro
pessoas vai desenvolver um problema
psiquiátrico
então a mensagem é se conheçam olham nos
olhos das pessoas que estão perto de
você não precisa ser um amigo próximo um
familiar pode ser o porteiro do seu
prédio
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]